I mean I'm my fantasy serious of course
is is often compared to Tolkien and and
I've talked in many interviews about and
and I'd love talking I'm the biggest fan
in the world of Lord of the Rings
but me too yeah Tolkien's view of good
and evil in that is is you know evil is
externalized it's comes from Sauron or
Morgoth before it and and there are
there were you know orcs who are
absolutely irredeemable and you know the
good people get together and and stop
the orcs and most of the good people are
good I've always been more attracted to
two great characters and I've said in
many interviews well I do think the
Battle of good and evil is a great
subject for fiction but in my view the
battle for good and evil is waged within
the individual human heart and it's our
decisions we're all partly good and
partly evil and we make we make
decisions every day and we may do a good
thing on Wednesday and then an evil
thing on Thursday or a selfish thing and
it's all very complicated and that's
kind of the approach that I've taken but
I'm also a huge fan of Lovecraft and and
I think you are - from reading some of
your books and I see Lovecraftian
influences in things like the end of
revival that you know that the vision of
the afterlife there is a terrifying
Lovecraftian moment of the short story
uh the name of forgetting about the
standing stones that everyone who's like
them that's OCD that's a very much
forget it's just in really okay and yet
and the mist the mist is another
incredible story very Lovecraft II and
you know this mist escapes and who knows
what the hell is in there but it's
really scary in there it's gonna be a TV
series from spike to and I think it
might be interesting Wow
but but even though ICD Lovecraftian
things when I look at your books the
real villains are the people I mean you
know Carrie Carrie kills a lot of people
in that high school but she's not the
villain the villain is the mother and
the other kids who torment her and and
do that misery Annie Wilkes is what a
horrifying creation and one that one
that both you and I live in constant
terror of
any successful writer and and by the way
you know we were talking earlier in the
in the green room there and uh you know
Steve asked if anyone ever showed up my
home and people do occasionally a show
up at my home but the creepiest thing
that ever happened to me is one day
there was a package in my mail and I
opened it and it was just a paperback
copy of misery no letter nothing just
just some unknown it was from your
number I mean under the dome maybe you
can say the aliens are the villains
who've trapped it but it's really the
horrible ordinary people under the dome
who start doing these incredibly
horrible things to each other and Brady
Hartsfield is a you know very clear and
a vivid example of that just a human
being who's the mist is another one I
mean there's still of crafty and
monsters but it's the crazy religious
woman inside that in the thing who
really makes things a thousand times
worse so I don't know what are your
views on the nature of evil is there is
there an external evil in the universe
is it Sauron or Satan or or Cthulhu or
is it our own fucked-up human nature's
it's interesting because you're right
there
there's no Sauron in the Thrones games I
mean the evil weaves itself in and out
the same way that the good weaves itself
in and out of the characters
one of the things about that you know
the thing is I wrote a series of books
called The Dark Tower and and and those
books were all done basically the the
the Seven Dark Tower books are one long
novel that never got edited because they
were done there is short stories that
they are done it's limited editions from
Donald Grant press nobody edited them
and nobody copy edited them so I went
back and I revised the first one and I
really need to go back to all of them
now one of the things in there that to
me is a problem is there's a my version
of Sauron was the Crimson King you know
and you see this mark the eye of the
King all the time that's outside evil
and in a way outside evil is a more
comforting concept than you know the
idea that the devil made me do it
is a way of sucking responsibility and
saying that I'm not there so I think
that we all understand that evil is
inside a lot of people and yet at the
same time I think that what a lot of and
I'm not expressing this very well but
what a lot of horror fiction does and
what a lot of fantastic fiction does is
it allows us to grapple with the outside
evil that strikes us you know you get a
call on the phone that says your cousin
is dead because he was in that Orlando
nightclub or you get a call like in the
thing that makes end of watch start you
get a diagnosis from the doctor that
says you have cancer and you're probably
going to die within the course of 16 17
months because this thing's just gone
too far and it's the kind that's you
know in the book it's pancreatic cancer
it's not a spoiler really because it's
on page nine for Christ's sake so so
don't yell at me I hate this thing about
spoilers Wow useful
all this you spoil that you can't spoil
a book Jesus Christ is a story I mean
you you go in there there have the
experience it isn't like you know
getting a GI Joe from the you know in
the in your cereal box is something to
sled so there are two kinds of evil
there's inside evil and this outside
evil and I think that when we have the
stories like you know in and the love
crafty and stuff where we're trying to
cope with the sort of things that happen
in our lives that are bad things that we
don't understand